welcome welcome everyone
i'm magnet from nano street marketing
and it is my pleasure to open the second
day for the special answer trilogy
yesterday we focused on oncology today
on immunology and tomorrow on
neuroscience research
please know that this is a live webinar
and we encourage you to ask your
questions
using the question and answer box you
find on the left of your screen
we will answer all of your questions if
we can today live
after the presentations and now i it's
my pleasure to
introduce to you our chair today dr doug
brown
doug is the chief executive of the
british society for immunology
the bsi and leads its mission to support
and transform immunology research to the
benefit of human and animal health
using the global reach of the bsi
they're building a best-in-class
membership
offer aimed at supporting research and
immunologists at all stages of their
career
as well as leading national and
international initiatives
to create a thriving environment
entirely in the immunology research
sector
and ensure that research is translated
into the clinic
doug has an immunology background having
completed a phd at cambridge university
on hiv research
the post doctoral position on malaria
and stem cells
does work for the ms society leading
their biomedical heritage program
works on the alzheimer's society as
chief policy and research officer
and he led a number of a high-profile
initiative including the very
important one establishing the 300
million
uh uk dementia dri dementia and research
institute
that is also trustee of the association
of medical research charities
and it's really a pleasure to having
today sharing the session
zag over to you now thank you agnes and
i must say that pleasure is
all mine so thank you for that kind
introduction and welcome
everybody to this afternoon session um i
don't know how many of you
know the british society for immunology
or our members i would hope a lot of you
are members given that you're tuning
into an immunology webinar but if you're
not
please do visit our website because
there's a lot that we do offer
our members um access to events to an
annual congress
career support travel awards we do lots
of advocacy on behalf of immunology
influencing policy and the government
and work on a number of exciting
initiatives across
cancer immunology vaccination and lots
of other areas so
i guarantee you if you're not currently
a member become a member you will not be
disappointed and one of those exciting
initiatives that we have been working on
over the last few months is in fact this
partnership
with nanostring and illumina which has
been a fantastic
partnership they've been a great couple
of companies to
work with to bring this award and this
technology cutting-edge technology
to two award winners for free to support
immunology research and so it's been a
real pleasure and we will hear from
those award winners later on i will come
to those
but before you hear from the award
winners i
want to actually hand back to agnes
and uh and then agnes will hand on to a
uh another
um colleague at illumina to give some
presentations from the companies so
agnes will speak first
from nanostring agnes over to you
thank you very much doug and um yeah i
just would like to have an input
to give an introduction on the spatial
biology that we're going to cover today
just to give you a background so
understanding the organization of cells
and tissues and how this organization
influences the function is a fundamental
question in life science research
but why is this the case so you can see
in this
schematic here an example of this point
of the y
when adopting a bulk rna analysis on
maybe responders
versus non-responders for example you
may get the same result as indicated
here
in the heat map when you instead
interrogate
excuse me interrogate specific areas in
the tissues maybe
an immune rich area versus an immune
poor
area you can really see the difference
that was averaged out
in the bulk analysis so going especially
is very important to find biomarkers
so basically here you see the genomics
where basically we merge
the power of high placed gene expression
and the resolutions
of imaging and so with genomics you can
really resolve in c to the full
transcriptome
and understand complex tissues and cell
interactions
so the flexibility to apply to apply
special genomics
on a sort of hypothesis-driven
or discovery focused experiment has been
really noted last year and in fact in
2020
the nature method of the year was indeed
was indeed the resolution of the
transcriptome institute
and atlanta saying we are very excited
and honored that geomix was selected for
such important
journal and paper and accolade in
essence
so let me just talking about paper let
me just show you some of the ones that
have been
already published with geronic we have
about 50 there will be a review of
course
some may be covered in important
journals like
nature medicine cancer research nature
and you can see that your peers have
been really active already in the field
of spatial biology
i want to tell you a couple of words
about the technology
so that you can start to follow a bit
even more the presentations they are
following
after myself so the technology is really
based on
either antibodies if you want to measure
proteins
or if you want to measure rna you use
instead of reservation probe
but for both cases in our technology we
leverage
special dsp products that are
essentially
indexing oligarchs that are attached to
the molecule
they are attached to via a photo
cleavable linker
so the dsp barcode has a unique sequence
which is really unique to the molecule
that it is attached to
and also as we said there is a
photoclipable link
identified with the dot here which is
really um
release the dsp by code when uv light
is shown now the workload flow itself
starts with the staining of your slide
so um basically um
the step one is staining um
and hybridize a cocktail of either
incetubilization probes
or antibodies labeled with the dsp
barcode
to your tissue together with morphology
markers that are fluorescently labeled
so that you can see your tissue and in
step two select your region of interest
in the picture here the region of
interest is represented with those
circles
but you can really follow the morphology
of the tissue and decide that you want
to investigate a specific
part of your tissue for example an
example in immunology could be that you
want to measure
uh the rna contained in the part of the
tissue that has been infected by
covalent versus the part of the tissue
that has not been infected by copies
so you can instruct geomics to shine the
light that you realize on those specific
area to release the barcodes on the
region of interest that you are
interested in
these barcodes are then collected and
dispensed on the
9612 plates that you you see there and
then eventually counted
either on the encounter or on one of the
fantastic illumina instruments
and next generation sequences and this
is why we have a great collaboration
with illumina because
our workflow is absolutely connected so
once the barcode is counted you just
you have a file represented here in the
table that table is then
put back into the software in the geomet
instruments that really put back
the information the high plex gene
expression information
back into the tissue so with this i hope
i've explained and shared with you
and you can appreciate how genomics can
help you detect
all targets measure proteins as well as
rna
explore any region that you would like
to investigate
on ffp tissue archive tissue as well as
fresh for frozen and of course it gives
you the flexibility
of profiling large compartments or even
specific
cell types so and i look forward to
listen to the presenters later on which
will make this all very very here with
real biology and data but for now i
passed it over
to uh to pablo
thank you very much uh agniessa for this
great
introduction and thank you very much
doug for
uh for uh sharing this session
so my name is tavel zayak i'm part of
illumina's marketing team
and i have the great pleasure of in the
next two or three minutes to
briefly present who we are and what we
do and i really find this field of
spatial biology so exciting because
biological systems tissues organs they
have a precise organization
because it's important to their function
and being able to look at
expression within this tissue context is
truly groundbreaking
and can tell you so much more about
biology
and illumina we are a global company and
we develop
manufacture and market innovative next
generation sequencing and microarray
technologies
and our technology enables you to make
foundational discoveries to transform
medicine and ultimately to impact life
and today there are more than 200 000
publications where
our technology has been used so it
clearly shows that this is a robust
technology
giving you results that you can trust
and you can either
purchase a system implement it in-house
in your own lab
but you can also get access to our
technology through
one of the many service providers that
are found
throughout the world and we do offer
next generation sequencing and depending
on how you prepare your sample
for next generation sequencing so
depending on how you do the library
preparation
this opens up a wide menu of biological
modalities
so you can study different facets of dna
you can study different types of rna
you can do work at the single cell level
and as agnes are very nice
illustrated you can also do
spatially resolved analysis
and our sequencing system in particular
the
nexseq 2000 which you can see here
giving you 1.1 billion reads and the
nova 6 system giving 20 billion read
they are an excellent match to the
nanostring geomics
aphas so the cancer transmittal matlab
and the whole transcriptome atlas
giving you the power to do those
discovery studies
to find out more about your biology
and we definitely also want to
streamline the data analysis part
so now you can find the geomix pipeline
in our base base sequence app which is
our cloud-based solution for data
analysis and data storage
and this particular pipeline will
basically take the reads
and it will create a digital count
conversion file
and you can then upload that file into
the geomix digital spatial profiling
to do analysis and to do visualization
and if you have any questions about the
sequencing
solutions we are more than happy to
assist
so please don't hesitate to get in touch
so with this i wanted to very much thank
you for your attention and hand the word
back to doug
that's fantastic thank you very much uh
pavel and agnes for your
presentations great to see these
technologies and how
uh they they can be applied and now
ladies and gentlemen it's on to our
award winners who have and are planning
to
use these technologies now i'm i saw the
award um nomination process um
when it was happening a few months ago
with applications coming in
across uh the whole of europe there was
fierce competition
for these awards and the judges reviewed
them all and decided on two
award winners and and have noted that
the the award winners
were um presenting innovative research
and really exciting ideas that did
deserve accessing this technology for
free to further their research
so the award winners are as you've
probably seen already
professor suzanne craftsman and dr
michelle
norton today we're going to hear from
both of them
and uh and then after that session we
will have
a q a session so both speakers will
speak
and then i will ask questions of each of
the speakers so please do get your
questions
in there's a question uh submission
functionality on the webinar platform
get those questions in and i'll ask as
many of those questions as i can of our
speakers
so welcome suzanne and by uh
introduction suzanne as i'm sure many of
you know
um has carried out her research in
various academic centers
across the world suzanne has previously
worked at the harvard medical school
on microglia dysfunction and prion
clearance
and has worked in the virology and
immunology research fields
in gertingen today suzanne is the group
leader and head of the core facility of
mouse pathology
at the university medical center hamburg
eppendorf institute of
neuropathology and today suzanne will be
presenting her work
on the blood-brain barrier dysregulation
in covid19
suzanne give it to you all right doug
thank you very much for this nice
introduction i'm very excited to be
here and as doug already pointed out
i'm really sitting in the center between
immology
brain diseases neurodegenerative
diseases and
high quality immunohistochemistry and
today i would like to present you our
work about blood brain barrier
dysregulation in kubit 19
and although kuvit is a respiratory
disease
it's becoming more and more obvious that
there are also severe
like side effects on the brain so
you have neurologic dysfunction in
severe copic cases
but also in survivors and patients that
recovered
from severe kovid you have the sukho
with a local weight
which is also going on at hand with the
neurologic dysfunctions like this in
this headache
and um but also more like severe
things like seizures and stroke so
um we were really interested what's
going on
in the brain and the city of hamburg
is also a state within germany so it's a
bit
um like independent and when um
kobe started in march last year
the authorities of hamburg ordered every
patient to be autopsied
to get like a hand on this pandemic and
also on the underlying comorbidities to
find out
more about what is happening in severe
covet 19 and from this we actually
investigated more than 40 cases
that died in the first
german wave of coronavirus disease
and from this um we actually um
check the brains to see what is going on
and actually there's not too much going
on because we checked for markers of
estrogliosis gfip
in like microglia activation
invasion of peripheral cells like
t-cells
in cd8 and if you see the overview
and you see that it's quite correct so
um this is what i actually wanted also
to show you
that there's not um really a trend to
their patients that's
like present with estrogens but there
are also
patients that do not present with
estrogens so
it's a rather fuzzy picture that we are
seeing here
and obviously we were interested in
the fact is that really entering the
brain and if so
where is it going then and for this we
first
um start to establish a really decent
um immunohestochemical staining to
detect
um a rask of two infected cells
and to do so we first infect the cells
and
put them into paraffin blocks because
obviously
um for patient material
um the tissue of choice is always
like embedded paraffin blocks you you
because of biosafety
reasons you rather never work with fresh
tissue
and um a lot of people might know that
this is always
um a bit tricky to work with paraffin
embedded
tissues thus um we checked this first
and we infected two types of cells or
viruses
which are like a very great
replicator for a lot of human pathogens
and in human neuroblastoma cell line the
shsy5y
cells and then we did not
infect or infect here with the red arrow
and tried a lot of different antibodies
to see
if they work on paraffin and better
tissues
and as you might see already
there are antibodies that do not work at
all
then there are antibodies that you show
um like a love background and are thus
not suitable
for um like detection of the earthquake
two in paraffin
sections but then there are also
antibodies
that um work really nicely so with this
we moved on to
um like tissues and these um
especially good ones and so we
first checked the lung tissue and then
we could see
wow yes it's working very decently in
lung tissue that doesn't give you any
background
or then recognizes very nicely and very
specifically
cells that are infected in people that
are like decreased with copic 19
and um but i have to tell that um
these are all lungs of people that died
out of
from covet 19 so it's not that you find
it everywhere this was also something we
had to learn
during our study it can look like this
but there can also be just single cells
um being positive like this and there
are also a lot of
even lung tissues that are not positive
at all
so um going back to the cells i mean
viruses
are very um efficiently infected and
tigers rise
um very easily and in the
neurobus tumor cell line it was not as
strong
um as it was in the other cells
so the scale is much smaller here you
see
that there is some infection ongoing
but it's um the degree is much smaller
so
neuronal cells might be infected but
it's not very efficient and actually
what we then detected in brains and
with brains i mean like more than like
60 70 that we checked by
t um there's positive
single cells so we do not see
overwhelming amounts of virus in the
brain
um and what we also saw
is that that does not um really
um correlate with those tissues
that show high activation of immune
cells
so this might also because we are
talking about
old people we are talking about people
with underlying diseases
and comorbidities so what we saw might
not
even be um like um
utica so it's uh very broad pictures
however um other people also
showed um or like
implicated neurons as the source for
for virus or also the blood brain
barrier
so in another project um on we also
checked for
um like um
immune or abundance of immune cells
around the vessels in the brain and we
actually could see
that there are um several patients that
showed um like immune
activation and also recruitment of
peripheral
immune cells to perivascular spaces
so um this led us to speculate that
there might be something going on at
least in a subset of patients
and in another project we also worked
with peripheral weather so this is from
the arteria carotis here
one of the main vessels in the body and
indeed
um we also could show that
zars cough two is abundant
in a very small subset of endothelial
cells
embodied this abundant and when we bulk
sequence this
we could also see that here case
four and five um like in contrast to
control one and two
um you see that there's quite some
changes going on
and there were quite some genes um down
regulated in the peripheral vessels
and these um where wessel um were mainly
um in like four categories
and um interestingly um
one category is infrared gamma pathway
and this was downregulated in the
peripheral vessels that we checked
but coming coming back to the brain um
the which ways um
are like um open forces to enter the
brain
i mean we checked medulla in our first
study
and could not see so much positive virus
positive cells there
so probably the medulla might not be the
entry point
for vascular ii people checked nasal
epithelium
and the vulvas are factorials that might
be
one root of entry but then we have the
blood-brain barrier and then
if you have immune cell recruitment you
might also have vessel leakage
you might also have transfer of that con
cos2
with the immune cells into the brain
parenchyma
or you might just have simply have work
by invariant dysfunction
and to sort this out in a bit more
detail
and an easy to go model um we at the
university medical center in hamburg
teamed up with the fraunhofer institute
specifically with olaples
who is the head of a biomarker and
translational drug discovery and they
developed an
ipsc derived tumor blood brain barrier
model
and this um we actually used
um to infect cells and the transverse
model
so the upper reservoir is then
representing the westerlund
and we placed the um darth croft ii
from the resolume and the lower would
then be
um like represent the brand parenchyma
and the big question was
are these cells infectable at all and
then we did
immune like cyto isochemistry
and we could indeed see that a subset of
cells get infected with earthquake too
and when we quantified we could see that
this is about
0.5 of all the sets so
it's not highly efficient but it's there
um so we then checked for the
receptors and we could identify that
h2 the main receptor is um low but it's
abundant on this brain cell
as are the cofactors temperatures 2 or
nrp1 and then we also
checked in the available literature and
here for example for
our endothelial cells on the block brain
barrier
nrp1 is highly abundant and um
caffeine l but ace is also abundant in
traces like we detected
in our blood-brain barrier model but
um then we were like also doing
immunohistochemistry
on some of our brains which is like
really
um in line with the amount that we
found in our ipc model but what would
also
like known from the literature and
um but then we got kind of a bit stuck
and i was rather thrilled um
[Music]
when i got
from another string because we like
had to duck [ __ ] um or poke a bit um
like in the haystack and we like checked
some comments for you like
a dysregulation markers that were known
in the brain
here for example pkm1 but this was
completely
not um like unchanged between control
patients
and and with nitin patients that's that
we thought okay we
should really get a bit more specific on
this
and um as i said we were rather
um like excited when i got
the code grant because it really offers
to take these brains from this poor
pipeline
died from kubit and then really
um dissect only the areas of
interest and for this um
i got the opportunity to submit two
slides
and thus we checked here
are some of our paraffin blocks and from
the paraffin blocks
we specifically selected areas
that did not so much differ between the
immune phenotype
because they were actually more
interested in the blood brain barrier
itself like the endothelial cells and
the estrogen
and feet then to get like these rather
strong immune phenotypes
as i said we selected areas with
like um comparable amount of
astrogliosis
or microglia activation and from these
we then um like um
made like this um
like punches and then we arranged the
punches so
we always had like six different um
patients and control
on one slide to get also
like very like heterogeneous um
um basics
for um settings
for detection of our weathers and so
we in total five control
brains and seventy seven
occur with nineteen patients and we
submitted our slides to the
rt facility of nano strain in seattle
and this was really really very exciting
because then i could live select
48 um wizards
in the human brain and for morphology
markers we
choose cd 31 as a um like
vessel marker gfip
for the astrocytes also to visualize the
astrocyte
and freaks that are surrounding whistles
also again to
exclude um like specific vessels that
have a super highly activated phenotype
and also cd45 which is a common marker
for immune cells and obviously dna to
show nuclei and this is how it looks
then
so our 12 12
brain punches when and here we choose
cortex tissue because this is a
like center where you have cognition and
where also
things like dizziness and
this brain fog thingy that you
frequently have and cool with 19 or
longer with
um like civilized um you have so we
choose
um here are the like frontal cortex
and um here's an example
of the vessels i picked so we try to get
like um
kind of more or less um
like equal size and i also try to excise
them very thoroughly
so like only the vessels and
we picked like three to five vessels per
grain
so i already told you a total of 48
vessels
and in this area so we're
like an average of about um
like 27 cells but we had sell
counts from eight sales to 67 towns
so i was very curious whether like the
smaller wizards was like eight cells i
also
gave decent results and i was so happy
because i really gave super good results
and the
quality control turned out okay for all
48 weeks so um
when we then made kind of a heat map
and here the quick 19 patients are in
this
green hue whereas controls controls and
this
like more like pink shoe you could see
that already here in this overview
um these um the patients um or the
weather
the vessel like transcriptome cluster
um really into groups um that represent
um kovid passions very nicely
and when we then checked um like for
genes
that are really highly significant
we could really sort out several genes
that
are up regulated in these endothelial
cells
in covid19 brains we were very exciting
about this
um and especially these chains that are
upregulated because
um some of those um
are also and and you might recall that
we checked already peripheral vessels
where the interference gamma pathway is
downregulated
and interestingly and of node interferon
gamma pathway is upregulated
in the coping 19 veins and i just saw
another manuscript out in last week
where um the interference gamma pathway
is also
up in um endothelial cells and this was
i we call it just um black sequencing
in in the guts so also another organ
which is suffering from um like
an infection because you also have
diarrhea and so on it's not really
sorted out
what um like um the ask of two infection
is doing there
and um especially two genes
efficient one ephesian two are really
standing out in this analysis so this is
also ongoing um research that we are
currently doing
to figure out what that might mean for
our patient
with um kuvit and so
we are like a huge step further into
elucidating what's going
on in in syria with 19 however
there are still a lot of questions to be
addressed um
so and it's still i mean not
not highly clear what's going on in
those brains
and um so on what's the long-term
consequences of co-igniting
so probably there is
like in our hands there's not so much
going directly on with um the virus in
the brain
but there is going on a lot um with
whistle dysfunction in the brain so this
is really
something that should be investigated
further and with this i would
like to thank my co-workers in the
institute of neuropathology
where i'm located mainly christine
hartmann and erits
my direct co-workers and
like collaborators in my work group
but also olap plus from fraunhofer
institute here in hamburg
other co-workers from the uk and the
southern nh
and which is suzanne feverly because she
did the virus infections of the cells
and fabian heinrich
at the legal medicine because he really
gave access to super high quality
like with 19 tissue which was a
prerequisite to get this super nice
and data with the nano string
[Music]
geo max settings and i would also like
again to thank the nanostring people for
giving me this grant and also for liang
cathy and
jan to support me um with
my project and with this i'm going
giving back to doug thank you a lot
that's wonderful i mean what a
presentation suzanne and you definitely
made the most of accessing
that technology and what's just
fantastic is is your passion
for this research coming across so thank
you very much for
sharing that with us we will come back
to you so
don't hang up you can disappear but
don't hang up we'll come back to your
questions
at the end and just a reminder to you
all can you please get your questions in
because we want to ask
loads of questions of our speakers
towards the end of this session
before we come to our next speaker we've
got a little bit of audience
participation
so if i could ask alexis who is in the
background here
excellent um there is a poll and so
um what we would like to hear from you
all is um around conducting spatial
research
you know what analyte will you be
focusing on is it rna
is it proteins or is it both rna and
protein so if you can please click
on this and your results will come in
we'll give you a couple of seconds this
is really useful data
for the companies and it will just be
interesting to see how you want to
access these technologies i think um and
so i think we'll
close the poll there and shall we view
the result i think
i can click on this to view the results
so we can be
open with the results that's what we
like to be
um interesting so
zero percent just rna
good proportion of your third on
proteins and two thirds on rna and
protein so
well thank you very much for uh filling
out that poll if we have time there's
another poll later on we do like a
little bit
of audience participation here um
so um thank you for um clicking on that
poll we now move on to
our second talk which will be our
presenter
dr michelle norton welcome michelle
and michelle as a bit of background
received a masters in neuropharmacology
and supported research on the modulation
of the glial scar before pursuing a phd
on the activation of endoplasmic uh
reticulum stress signaling
in myelination at the national
university of ireland
galway her current project which uh she
is doing as a research fellow at queen's
university
involves studying the regenerative
profile of immune cells
in multiple sclerosis so um
i believe the presentation as it says
here will be uh to investigate uh
tertiary lymphoid structures in ms so
michelle it is now time to hand over to
you
um great uh thank you so much doug and
um
yeah it's been fantastic to be here and
to hear about what you know what that
technology has already brought to
suzanne and
we're a little bit earlier where i don't
quite have um we haven't quite started
yet with actually i'm performing the
profiling yet and getting the data out
but we're so excited to see what it's
going to
but yeah so just to explain i'm from
queensland
and the welcome austin institute for
experimental medicine with fresher
fixtures
group and in this group we are trying to
identify new strategies and
new targets to um new targets for
multiple processes by
uncovering new knowledge about how the
immune system influences the central
nervous system whether that's
um by stimulating regeneration but also
in looking at
how it affects pathogenesis obviously
and
this project investigating tertiary
lymphoid structures and a mess we feel
could have a big impact on
um uh yeah just to explain a bit more
about
who aren't as familiar about it and
uh yeah it's the most common uh
disabling chronic neurological condition
that affects young adults so that's
2.8 million people globally and there's
a strong female biases
69 of them are female and the average
age of diagnosis is 32 years old so
that's just when people are forging
their careers their families their
relationships
and um even coming to that diagnosis can
take quite a long time because it's a
very heterogeneous disease
and the range of symptoms that people
can experience can vary from like
numbness
tingling to having difficulties with
walking bladder function
fatigue um there's there's a huge range
of symptoms and it can take
quite a while to actually come to that
diagnosis um
but in the clinic they are able to see
common clinical patterns
so 85 people will present with the
relaxing remission um uh
uh pattern after these at onset which
means that their clinical symptoms will
wax away
and then after a certain period of time
they enter what we call a progressive
phase where their
disability increases in the absence of
relapses
and um for that uh other 15
people with ms they only ever
experienced that type of progressive
phase of disease and they would be
called primary progressive
um and the diagnostic hallmarks of ms
are these white matter lesions that are
detected by mri in the brain that are
disseminated in time and space um
we know that when we look histologically
that these correlate to these
areas of smiling a lot where um here
with myelin and blue you can see that
the
you know various dark areas where um the
myelin has been stripped off the axons
and they're that that are now just
completely white and you also see these
paler areas here where there is has been
some
um repair that would cover remyelination
um and histologically we do get like
a lot more detail than we than you can
do by mri and even going back to like
1916
they were able to see that um that
even that the you know accents were
still being feared even while these
phagocytic macrophages were stripping
the myelin sheath that was around them
and even then it was noted that um even
in the cortex
you know where there's far less myelin
um or or next to none
um as would have appeared to them then
that you could also see subtle changes
um in the cortex but for a very long
time ms was considered
a white matter disease um it was even
considered to be
a purely motor disease for a long time
and this them caused
it caused untold stress basically for
for the people that were experiencing
it until they like really came to
understand that it's a disease that
affects the
whole brain and i think the history of
ms research it really goes to show how
important
a detailed spatial awareness of what
exactly is happening in the tissue
is so important to understand the these
processes
and you know how it really has brought
on our field so much
so i'm going to be highlighting um
a couple of these neglected um
pathological features
and that were and i didn't receive
attention for a long time but then
you know um but then i've made a real
contribution to the msps since we have
done
and this is why i'm so excited about you
know getting to use digital spatial
profiling with our tissue but we've come
to that
so the first one i was going to mention
was the normal appearing white matter so
this is the white matter that
you know for all intents and purposes
like you would have seen here with the
um
the nice blue brain you can see the very
obvious areas
um that were very obvious areas that
had been affected um by the disease but
the other areas of flu are also under
severe stress
and this was noted back in the seventies
by our own
and professor daniel ingrid allen and
i mentioned her because she was a a
noted neuropathologist that established
a very important tissue collection
um containing um lots of
uh containing a whole range of cases of
demyelination and other diseases that is
still really um
they're still capable of really bringing
a lot of new knowledge to the field
so i wanted to mention that um yeah this
was one of her
one of several seminal contributions
that she made to the field but
she showed that 72 of samples of this
normal appearing white matter
were histologically abnormal when you
actually um look at it in detail and
this proved to be insightful because
um even just very recently there's been
um
a report that early tissue damage in the
normal appearing white matter
can characterize a subtype of disease
and that this is predictive value for
disability progression and treatment
response so you can imagine about what
difference that that can make to
um what difference this could
potentially make for for
patients that you could actually gain
that knowledge from knowing what's
happening in the normal appearing white
matter
um another example that was neglected
for um
quite a long time was um that ms is also
a gray matter disease and not just a
disease of white matter
engage the lesion area um in the green
matter cancer path
the area of white matter lesions it's uh
it's as well as being an immune mediated
condition it's also a neurodegenerative
condition and you'll see
secret neuronal density both in the
normally appearing gray matter and in
the demyelinated
green matter lesion area in ms and
even more than that we find that grey
matter pathology is a better predictor
of
disease trajectory that free matter data
image will correlate with
disability milestones um in that
if you have a greater potential free
matter damage that you
um tend to have an earlier obsession
disease uh
earlier time that um a person may
use a wheelchair and an earlier time to
climb to death and that also that
cortical atrophy of certain brain
regions
um has been shown to be predictive of
cognitive decline
um so it's a really important aspect of
the disease that
um we all that
um that ms researchers are very
conscious of now that it's not just
a disease of the white matter that it's
a disease of the whole
brain and if we want to um that we
really need to understand the drivers
behind
um free matter pathology if we are to
really tackle
um ms so this brings us to
like one more um
feature of the um pathological feature
of the disease which
um i feel has been neglected for a long
time up until relatively recently which
is meningeal inflammation and this could
be
um one of the key drivers of
brain matter pathology and um
this is the and this will be the focus
of our project that we want to apply
um with using data string and illuminous
and
technology so just to explain a little
bit more about what we mean by the
meninges are these um membranous um
layers that surround the brain and
spinal cord
so there's three layers the the outer
more
simple dura mater then you have the
subarach then you have the arachnoid
which could change the subarachnoid
space where you'll have three
spinal fluid and then and finally this
is very thin membrane and cause the pia
matter which would be
directly overlying the cortex and
but it not only just contains through
the spinal fluid it is home to numerous
immune cells
um and if you uh classify
um the degree of inflammation in ms
patients
um you'll find that those uh if you
compare between those with the least
level of
energy information to those of the very
highest levels of energy information
that there is very fair contrast and the
level of free matter pathology
and that that's occurring just
directly beneath them there as you can
see in these two examples
um much of the work that i'm going to
describe here has been done by dr owen
howell's lab which is a
very important collaboration of ours on
this project and um
um yeah one of the reasons why we uh
um why i feel it's been neglected up
until recently which i wish i meant to
mention was that um
these synergies were often just
discarded for a long time after
you know during the brain dissection um
process and the anatomy lab so they
would simply have um taking them off
which now just you know horrifies me
because now that i know just how um
just how much uh information we can
actually gain from them and you know
their their own
uh contribution that they can make to
the um
to the disease course as shown here with
um
in this graph that having a higher
degree of meningeal inflammation are at
least having again
an earlier unsaturated disease um
being at an earlier age when you've
reached that progressive phase
or reach the point in which you use a
wheelchair or indeed to reach
the point at which um the patient dies
so it's incredibly important that we
understand
meningeal inflammation better and um
as that is what we're going to be aiming
to do with this um
and this category of information the
very highest category of information is
where we see what we
what i'm calling the tertiary employee
structures um
uh and there is um there's been a little
bit of debate about them um
but just to show you what um
um our description of these lymphoid
structures you might
also have heard of them as these
um but they are semi-organized
aggregates of museum cells
um containing t-cells and proliferating
b cells
um amongst others that um are present
and are usually found
nestled within the meninges and the deep
soul side of the brain as you can see
here by these red dots
um now in this graph here this wouldn't
be a single
um ms patient wouldn't contain this
amount of
um follicles but this is um
uh this is a like a like a heat map if
you like of the most common
um most common locations in the brain
right you might find
a tertiary lymphoid structure um
so this is part of um and this work here
that
um identifies that tertiary lymphoid
structures although they're more common
and secondary progressive than this
but they can also be observed in cases
within even just a few short years
before
a few short years of disease duration
before
um unfortunately the patient died um
and one of the uh this work was
supported with tissue from the dame
ingrid allen
um tissue collection that we have here
in belfast and so
um uh and that's that you can see that
with some of the images here
um comes directly from this collection
so just to describe a little bit more
about it that
um it contains over 300 cases of
ms and other neurological diseases and
they're fft tissue and um it ranges
from going back to the four sheets all
the way up to
the 1990s and so the vast majority of
these samples are before the advent of
ms treatment
and this means that you can look at the
natural disease pathology
and indeed the indulgence repair
processes that that occur in the tissue
um and it also includes some very rare
cases including these
instances of um including these samples
where
they had a very short duration of ms
before they died so this would be
um relatively rare to find in tissue
banks and especially nowadays thank
goodness
to thanks to the wide range of
treatments that we have nowadays
um for ms but um
but these could be really highly
valuable examples when it comes to
finding out you know what is happening
early in the disease process and that is
what we want to do now that we
you know we are lucky enough to have
access to this resource of
um with this resources issue and thanks
to dr
winehouse expertise that we'll get to
investigate
um tertiary infrastructures in mms
and i'll just tell you a little bit more
about that now
and so i am working with um
um i'm co-supervisor for um dr rachel
key who's a phd student on this project
and she is um uh
supervised between uh dr winehouse lab
and the lab here and
with professor james with shirt and
queen
and uh she has been um doing
a lot of work with them uh updating the
clinical classification so as you can
imagine
um with these cases some of them dating
back to the 1940s so
we need to make sure that these are um
clinically up-to-date
and you know that they correspond to um
to modern um classifications for ms
and that we can definitely send over um
the that there is sufficient clinical um
information with them that we can
um properly have them define so that we
can short system properly for
youth in these studies and we've been
conducting comprehensive profile of
inflammatory indicators
in order to conduct this tertiary and
moisture screening
um and this is all with the aim that we
can uh provide the first
um comprehensive profile of the cellular
composition as well as the transcription
of territory lymphoid structures which i
feel is going to be
um a major contribution for this field
um and we'll be doing this via
multiplexing in
chemistry uh as well as um the
video with digital spatial profiling um
with nanosphering and alumina which um
we're going to be so
excited to see um
and we're also hoping then that because
uh
like the wizards of the collection we'll
be able to compare our changes in the in
these structures
um between those with
a short duration of a mess versus those
with a long duration of mms
hello everyone i i think we may have
lost michelle just at the end of her
presentation
we have had a couple of technical issues
this afternoon but i can assure you
it was just before the last slide so i'm
pretty sure she presented
most of her research hopefully we'll get
michelle um
joining us um again before we end the
webinar in a few minutes time so we can
ask her a couple of questions but
until then suzanne can we have you
return
to the digital floor um and begin the
q a session yes we have to exam
hopefully michelle will join us
in a second um so we have had some
questions in which is fantastic
people if you still have some questions
there's time to put them in uh the box
they're flashing up on my screen and i
will um ask them of the speakers
so see that i wonder whether to start
off
um and again fantastic talk um thank you
could you know could you tell us a
little bit about um
whether you've detected the virus in
neurons or
astrocytes um and whether you
investigated other brain regions as well
and there
is there an abundance of um sarskov2
does that change across the brain um
so in the first study that i also
presented today
we focused on medulla because this was
one of the pewter type
entry sites like going like up the spine
and um enter the brain uh while there
are
like nerves that um like goes through
the like
or into the medulla also coming from the
lungs or so
and we were really surprised to not see
like really much virus there
um were like about 50 cases
of positive for rna um
however um 50 of cases positive for rna
um but actually we never saw
um like um that
two in like specific brain cells i have
some
unpublished data where i try to do or
where i did
like triple fluorescent staining and
there it still looks as if it's rather
immune cells that carried the virus into
the brain
however you also have to be cautious
because we are always talking about
people and even in the lung you might
not find virus because it might have
been
cleared in the meantime
great thank you uh suzanne and welcome
back michelle we just lost you at the
end of your presentation there didn't we
great and i mean thank you for your
presentation it was fantastic even
though we lost the end of it we
managed to follow it all and um and
actually it's very close to my heart
because
of my time of working at the uk multiple
sclerosis society
um very much keeping an eye on the field
and how that's developing
so thank you very much for your insights
so we just asked um
a question of suzanne and actually i'm
going to ask you a follow-up question
because you mentioned um
the lungs and versus the brain and
did you see that the abundance in the
brain correlated with the abundance of
virus in the lung
um no not necessarily so i mean
you the the abundance is very rare
so what we see is that um
mainly and this is also a problem when
you take bulk tissue
for detecting um
tsars with rna techniques um it's more
correlating with ceremia and the
bloodstream
so this is also something you have to be
careful about because if you have highly
um like um like um um
like like tissues um
with a high blood flow you might just
detect virus
that is still abundant in the blood um
so
i mean as i said we only see some of
these cells still left on the brain
but it does not correlate okay now
that's that's really fascinating
and michelle coming to you these
tertiary lymphoid structures you know
how
how common are they in people with ms
and
is it specific to ms or other autoimmune
conditions
um well it's been found in up to 40
of um sbms cases looked at so far
um in terms of uh short duration or
relapsing remission
ms cases there haven't been enough um
looked at but we'll be hoping to
contribute to
with that information using the
collection that we have here so
um once we have that screening finally
completed we'll be able to
um
sorry i hope my connection is still
working um
yeah it is found in other autoimmune
conditions and it's usually
associated with a more severe disease
and it's also actually also found in
certain tumors and cancers where it's
actually
been found to be beneficial in some
cases with helping to resolve those
tumors
and so yeah we can definitely learn from
those other conditions as well
okay now that that's that's that's
fantastic and
i mean what's the significance do you
think of this and there's still a lot to
discover but for
people with ms who are living with the
condition and
you know is this something that can help
sort of diagnostic prognostic
treatment other yeah no that's that's
that's definitely what i hope we'll be
able to find with this research because
those that have this high degree of
meningeal inflammation which appears to
be driven by these tertiary lymphoid
structures that they're driving this
cortical pathology
and that they're having the most
severe cases of disease so you know
they're having a greater disease burden
as a result so the more that we can
understand about these
i'm hoping that we'll be able to find
another strategy to help to counteract
this
no that's great similar question to to
you
suzanne and i think we should probably
make this the final question given that
we've reached um
the the end of the hour um but uh the
significance of your research findings
to
cover 19 patients or any of us that
could be affected by kovid19 well how
how how does this um these insights
impact on maybe understanding the
disease and again
maybe treating preventing um the disease
in the future
and i asked the question um so they are
um
the question would be to um avoid
contact after ashcraft 2
with brain cells so like you could um
act on the very like beginning because
now also with um
diagnosing um or detecting
suscroft2 infections much earlier
you could like use inhibitors
but probably it would also be good to
like um really target the immune system
and this interferent gamma responses um
however we did not do research
um specifically on this yet so this
would probably
also be something that you could first
start to
evaluate on the blood brain barrier
model
um because um and this is also one point
i mean
we always have end stage when we
investigate
um like paraffin embedded tissues so
it's also something
that would be worth studying in the um
people that recovered con from kobe yet
that you follow up if they have really
or so
in different gamma signaling problems is
there's a
circulation going on and such
great that's wonderful i mean i could
ask questions of you
all evening long but i'm sure you've got
lots of things to do
and people viewing have lots of things
to do
as well so i'm afraid we're going to
have to end the
questions there apologies for some of
the technical issues you know it
wouldn't be a webinar unless there were
some so
i'm sure you have every sympathy for us
um
and i just wanted to say a huge thank
you um to the speakers in particular
uh suzanne and michelle azar award
winners
clearly you have in your art and you are
making um
a huge amount out of winning this award
and uh
and having access to this technology and
uh look forward to seeing
how your research develops um also once
a big thank you to the companies we
heard from agnes and pavel earlier
nano string illumina have been fantastic
to work with and it's been a real
pleasure and we
at the british society for immunology
look forward to working with them again
in the future perhaps around
another award scheme but plenty of other
options um
i'm sure and i'd like to also thank you
as the audience for joining us um this
afternoon
this evening this morning wherever you
have joined us from around the world i
saw
a very international audience when i had
a click through the participants there
um so thank you very much for for giving
up your time and
i hope you enjoyed these wonderful
presentations
from our award winners um i am told that
i need to remind you this is number two
in a trilogy of webinars and all the
best things coming threes of course
don't they
and the third and final one is tomorrow
which is a focus
on neuroscience so if you haven't
already and you are interested please do
sign up for that final webinar tomorrow
um so i think we're going to
um close the webinar with a short video
from
the companies so please do stay on and
watch that but
that's it from us again thank you to the
speakers thank you to the organizers
it's been a pleasure cheering you this
afternoon
do take care and goodbye for now
[Music]
after completing slide preparation which
is similar to ihc or
ish we will put our slice into the tray
and then we will put the tray into the
instrument and load buffer
next we will be ready to enter our slide
records and scan parameters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a fluorescent image with up to four
colors is generated
to enable selection of region of
interest or roi on this tissue
you as the user can choose these rois
from anywhere on your laptop
geometric profiling allows us to choose
circles
squares or even polygons
this would be a great tool when you have
pretty homogeneous regions
like immune cells and the tumor
segregated within one tissue or across
tissues
in your cohort geometric profiling was
utilized in david grimm's nature
communications article in 2020
many users can also create rules for
segmenting the rois
this would let morphology of the tissue
determine the
boundaries of the area of illuminations
or aois to enable 100 cellularity
for example users can create
tumor and tme segments across a tissue
sample as shown on this example
selected rois are illuminated with uv
light to release barcodes from dsp
probes
and then these dsp probes are deposited
into a 96 valve plate
[Music]
the release dsp barcodes are prepared
via a standard library preparation
so they can be read out on illumina
sequencers the data can be mapped
especially back to the originating
region of interest
samples can now be loaded onto your
illumina sequencer
depending on your experimental design
and the instrument capacity
you can read up to 760 rois from a
single geomics experiment
in a single illumina run here we have an
xc2000
which will allow us to easily read
hundreds of protein or rna analytes
once the task view files are generated
they'll be converted to digital code
comps
and then uploaded back to geomic.esp
[Music]
instruments
[Music]
the data analysis screen is divided into
three panes and a taskbar
here we describe the functions of each
pane and the interactions between all
three
the scan pane is shown on the left side
and contains
individual v-result sets in the middle
pane
we have our data sets and probe lists
on the right we have our visualization
pane
which shows the various graphs in this
case this is our
qc graph the middle data sets
pane lists all data sets and probe
groups associated with the current study
the visualizations pane is on the right
visualizations are visual
representations of the data set
selected and probe selected and the
adjustments applied to the
data set from those probes now i'm going
to open another study
here we can see the data has been qc'd
and normalized
once you normalize the data you can see
in your visualizations pin
different graphs including pathway maps
pathway tables bar graphs correlation
plots
box plots pca plots
trend lines and we can view heat maps
i'm going to end with clicking on a data
point on the data visualizations pane
and you'll notice that roi
associated with it will be zoomed in
on the left pane of the screen
presenting seamless integration of the
images and the digital cons
thanks for joining our customer
experience lab sessions